we can only imagine just how long it
would take to plow through all of
Netflix as many movies documentaries and
TV shows months maybe or even years with
so many titles available to subscribers
it can be easy to get a little
overwhelmed by everything the streaming
service has to offer luckily we've
compiled this list of a few of Netflix's
finest hidden gems the perfect go twos
next time you find yourself at a loss
for what to watch beyond skyline B
movies usually tend to get a fairly bad
rap thanks to their lower than average
budgets questionable performances and
poor scripts and let's be honest beyond
skyline fits snugly into pretty much all
of those categories the basic plot is
this aliens invade earth using a bunch
of high-tech blue lights which turn
people into zombies allowing said aliens
to harvest their brains enter Frank
Grillo as mark an alcoholic cop whose
principal method for dealing with the
aliens can be largely summed up as
punching them until they go away
so yes it sounds like your typical
b-movie dud but beyond skyline is
clearly a labor of love the movies
attention to detail betrays a passion on
the part of the filmmakers that you
struggle to even find in many of today's
big budget blockbusters also it's a lot
of fun if you've got a soft spot for
genre movies you'll have a blast
the boy on the surface the boy appears
to be your average run-of-the-mill
horror movie it's about a young American
nanny who takes a job caring for the son
of an elderly couple in the English
countryside she thinks they're playing a
joke when she discovers that their son
is actually a porcelain doll named
Brahms but soon begins to suspect that
there's more to the doll than meets the
eye underneath that pretty thin premise
however is a movie which is totally
willing to embrace its own silliness it
manages to spend just enough time poking
fun at itself to remain charming all the
while delivering a satisfyingly creepy
story and a solid twist ending the gift
this 2015 horror thriller written
directed by and starring Joel Edgerton
delivers on all fronts making for a
tense dramatic stalker flick that's
bound to keep you guessing to the end
Edgerton stars as Gordo a mysterious
loner who runs into an old friend from
high school
although Gordo might seem like your
typical outcast at first his sinister
intentions slowly become clear nothing
groundbreaking here then but the gift
benefits from a cast of well written
characters and a captivating approach to
morality before long you'll find
yourself questioning just who the
movie's real villain really is the tiger
hunter equal parts cheesy and sweet the
tiger hunter is the story of an Indian
immigrant in the late 70s who comes to
America in search of a job only to find
something even better a purpose it's a
total feel-good movie from start to
finish the kind of Jim best saved as an
antidote to some terrifying horror movie
a downbeat drama or anything starring
Sean Penn think of it as Prozac but with
better cinematography it's not a movie
that's going to change the world anytime
soon but you can't say it's not lovely
and sometimes that's enough
Pandora it's a story you'll probably
feel like you've heard before a nuclear
reactor goes haywire after a devastating
earthquake endangering the citizens of a
small South Korean town as various
government officials try to escape the
blame the ordinary folk do their best to
avoid the cataclysmic destruction of the
reactor itself so far so bland right
well stick around because towards the
end Pandora
suddenly transforms into something so
beautiful and touching that you can't
help but wonder if Netflix is autoplay
switch movies without you know too
seen the rest of Pandora is decent
enough but that ending is one for the
ages the perfect host david Hyde Pierce
best known for playing Niles on Frasier
here takes on a role as a high-strung
gentleman who unknowingly accepts a
criminal into his home on the eve of a
dinner party before long the script is
flipped and a whole slew of secrets
about both men are subsequently revealed
claimed Crawford co-stars as the hapless
criminal John Taylor and both he and
Pierce work hard to turn what could have
been a flat movie into a total thrill
ride the plot is riddled with twists
each building on the other until the
movie reaches a final fever pitch we
can't say much more without risking
spoilers queue it up and let it rip boys
in the trees
the events of this criminally underrated
Australian flick play out over the
course of one Halloween night as two
former friends one popular the other a
social outcasts reunite for a long walk
home filled with stories about their
childhood in their lost friendship as
each story is told boys in the trees
further embraces its McCobb fairy tale
tone reinforced by an array of colourful
visuals and anchored by the real-life
social conflicts each character faces in
their day-to-day life first time writer
director Nicolas verso balances those
two sides of the story perfectly never
allowing the fantasy to cheapen the
reality of the film or vice versa
it's both stunningly visceral and
chock-full of childhood wonder a rare
Jim indeed
[Music]